[Musica]
conservare il passato per progettare il
futuro è un tema che come vedremo a che
vedere con responsabilità di alloggi
ma cos'è progetto progetto è ideazione
piano proposta e at home ed
etimologicamente un gettare in avanti e
quindi è una previsione di futuro il
progetto sul costruito e list di un
sapiente dosaggio tra cosa conservare e
cosa trasformare alla luce della
conoscenza questo è un programma di
lavoro che do agli studenti ormai da
molti anni al politecnico di milano sul
tema del progetto tecnologico e ci
concentreremo ora sui temi del
conservate al trasformare della
conoscenza conservare perché perché gli
edifici sono testimonianze aventi valori
civiltà ci dice la commissione
franceschini e poi perché sono documenti
sono la sedimentazione fisica della
memoria collettiva e per questo vanno
conservati e poi perché l'articolo della
costituzione ci ricorda che la
repubblica tutela il paesaggio e il
patrimonio storico artistico della
nazione
ma che cosa dobbiamo conservare dobbiamo
conservare la materia si restaura solo
la materia dell'opera d'arte ci dice
cesare brandi cioè noi non restauriamo
l'artisticità non riportiamo la
primigenia bellezza noi conserviamo la
materia e la materia quella che
trasferisce i valori culturali estetici
e la bellezza ed è altrettanto
importante il dipinto quanta la tela che
lo supporta dal punto di vista
documentale
questa è una bellissima immagine di
marco introini questo è il patrimonio è
parte del patrimonio in italia
statisticamente misurati ma
probabilmente per difetto abbiamo 500
mila edifici che sono soggetti
assoggettabile a tutela ma poi abbiamo
tutti i siti unesco che sono centri
storici di intere città come venezia
roma napoli firenze
e poi abbiamo tutti i siti archeologici
solo pompei sono 60mila 60 ettari non
avremmo mai le risorse per conservarli
tutti e allora bisogna cambiare
strategia ed è quello che voglio
proporre oggi anche nella nostra
provincia abbiamo degli straordinari
oggetti che sono probabilmente poco
conosciuti e poco valorizzati questo
l'oratore visconti di avvisate qui in
questa immagine potete vedere
fisicamente il futuro che incontra il
passato è un edificio che è stato
costruito intorno alla seconda metà del
trecento un edificio che vede del un
ciclo di affreschi importantissimi fatti
da autori probabilmente allievi di
giovanni da milano e di giusto ne vuoi i
quali furono allievi di giotto e noi
sappiamo che giotto è venuto a milano
chiamato ad azzone visconti nel 1335 da
portato la tecnica dell'affresco in
lombardia anche il paesaggio è costruito
questa è un'immagine splendida del lago
di varese che era stato evocato anche
tra l'altro nella presentazione iniziale
un luogo magico anche un che ancorché un
po inquinato ma un luogo magico c'era
che racconta storie impensate che stiamo
cercando di valorizzare attraverso una
tesi di laurea specialistica a partire
appunto dal lago dai comuni rivieraschi
ed alcuni cassago rabbia che è stato
l'attivatore di questa iniziativa e poi
abbiamo tutto l'ambiente costruito il
paesaggio urbano che sono all'estero di
una commissione straordinaria di
residenze monumenti la cui bellezza è
data dalle relazioni coerenti che si
instaurano tra gli edifici e le piazze
tra i pieni e vuoti tra il iv e di cui
edifici pool b c ed edifici privati
allora ritorniamo al nostro tema
nel conservare abbiamo visto il concert
conservare vediamo il trash il
trasformare perché dobbiamo trasformare
gli edifici perché gli edifici sono
oggetti d'uso senza uso gli edifici
vanno in decadimento inevitabilmente
quindi l'esigenza della trasformazione
nasce dal fatto che le esigenze
dell'utenza sono in continua
modificazione ineluttabile modificazione
pensate che dagli anni 50
solo il 7 per cento degli del delle
abitazioni aveva il bagno l'acqua
corrente e l'energia elettrica negli
anni sessanta sono diventati il 28 per
cento
noi oggi sapete tutti difficilmente
riusciamo a vivere in abitazioni che
hanno che non hanno almeno due o tre
bagni e magari anche la vasca
idromassaggio allora noi potremmo dire
che la storia del restauro e la storia
delle trasformazioni che sono succedute
nel tempo e che si sono stratificate di
informazioni e conoscenze che sono
indispensabili oggi a noi per conoscere
il passato sono dei palinsesti
straordinari che devono essere
conservati ed è proprio la loro materia
che ce lo trasferisce che ci trasferisce
queste informazioni
però la trasformazione necessariamente e
selezione e modifica e allora il corto
circuito che si viene istituire tra
esigenze di caos di conservazione
necessari trasformazione è una questione
che io credo debba togliere sono gli
architetti perché quello che
distruggiamo e distrutto per sempre per
qualunque ragione noi lo facciamo
e allora veniamo al tema della
conoscenza scusate veniamo al tema della
conoscenza conoscere
no noi ognuno di noi vede quello che sa
in base a quelle che sono le sue
conoscenze capacità di interpretazione e
noi sappiamo anche che i valori ai quali
noi più volentieri ci riferiamo sono
valori sempre storicamente determinati
valori economici culturali d'uso sono
storicamente determinati nella storia ci
dice che tutte le volte che questi
valori sono stati fatti valere per
questioni
di natura estetico storia grafica hanno
sempre comportata comportato c'è censura
dell'esistente e distruzioni di materia
allora il tema che si pone è quello del
lasciare esistere lascia resistere
quello che anche oggi noi non siamo in
grado di riconoscere come valore perché
anche il futuro sia in grado di
suscitare nuove possibilità conservare
quindi è un imperativo ma è altrettanto
un imperativo il trasformare cioè
consentire che gli edifici vengano usati
e per fare che vengano usati devono
essere adeguati alle esigenze d'uso non
c'è utilizzo non c'è conservazione senza
uso semmai dobbiamo porci il tema della
compatibilità perché non tutti gli
edifici sono in grado di acquisire
attività di utilità in qualunque maniera
allora il metodo della conservazione e
la manutenzione intesa come cura nel
1849 john ruskin ammoniva prendetevi
cura solerte dei vostri monumenti non
avete alcun bisogno diresti di
restaurare lì sono passati 150 anni son
cose che sappiamo da tempo allora perché
perché il restauro è sempre un
intervento a guasto quando ormai il
degrado e avanzato si interviene nel
restauro allora è necessario pensare
interventi di manutenzione e la
manutenzione è possibile solo se ci si
prende davvero a cuore il patrimonio
perché non si può conservare solo ciò
che si ha a cuore che si riconosce come
parte integrante di un sistema complesso
di valori nei quali noi volentieri ci
conosciamo e che costituiscono
l'identità collettiva e qui faccio
vedere l'immagine che non so quanti
conosceranno in sala vista l'età media
questo è eduardo de filippo un grande
drammaturgo ma io presento questa
immagine perché perché ci fa capire che
quello che noi dobbiamo conservare sono
anche le rughe della storia
i segni del passaggio del tempo è
un'immagine come questa ci parla di
autenticità ci parla di esperienza e ci
parla
di verità allora se il metodo della
conservazione alla manutenzione
la strategia è quella della prevenzione
cosa vuol dire fare prevenzione vuol
dire fare interventi sostanzialmente di
controllo costanti continui nel tempo e
attività di piccola manutenzione che
sono però essenziali per garantire la
conservazione dei monumenti e guardate
la prevenzione è anche conveniente da
esperienze che abbiamo fatto
possiamo quasi certamente affermare che
i costi dalla nostra azione preventiva
possono essere compresi tra il 2 e il 4
per cento all'anno dal costo dell'intero
restauro quindi fare la manutenzione
conveniente e e i costi della
manutenzione sono elevatissimi in questo
ci vieni aiuto in aiuto alla tecnologia
il digitale oggi attraverso la
sensoristica è possibile tenere sotto
controllo gli edifici in tempo reale è
possibile gestire a distanza i cantieri
e in prospettiva
pensiamo all'edificio cognitivo cioè un
edificio che sia in grado sulle
suggestioni della domotica che sia in
grado di fornire informazioni e
interagire con le bisogni dell'utente
anche con i bisogni di carattere
culturale e allora cos'è futuro il
futuro e alla prossima uscita
e qui e qui sono 150 anni che ci diciamo
queste cose ricordavo prima quindi cos'è
il futuro e prevedere i processi di
invecchiamento per programmare gli
interventi manutenzione quindi il futuro
va anticipato non va rincorso e poi
possiamo dire che ogni passato è stato
anche un futuro è stato anche un futuro
ed è leggendo e studiando il passato che
possiamo sapere e conoscere perché oggi
ci siamo e siamo qui e siamo così e
siamo fatti così
e infine è necessario cambiare paradigma
da interventi di restauro fatti una
volta per tutte illusoriamente eventi
eclatanti che danno ritorni di immagine
ad attività invece
proseguite nel tempo con attenzione cura
amore per il passato
e allora siamo davvero alla fine
sant'agostino ci diceva parafrasandolo
un po che il passato non c'è già più
il futuro non c'è ancora quello che
conta è presente noi siamo nel presente
ed enel presente che dobbiamo agire
abbiamo a disposizione tutte le
conoscenze di carattere culturale
tecnologico organizzativo per fare il
meglio che lo possiamo cominciare a fare
già da domani giorno per giorno in
questo ci aiuta questa riflessione di
abramo lincoln che appunto dice che la
migliore cose del futuro e che arriva un
giorno alla volta
grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]